i have a what to watch story  today is uh going to be a special guest  on the premiere of drum roll  reading rainbow live yay  set the stream on march 6th the theme of  the interactive event will be kid  inventors and so vlad is going to be  joined by the young inventor sammy vance  she's also an author yes families can  buy tickets and get streaming details at  readingrainbowlive.com and vlad can you  hook me up this is can we go back to  that picture of lad wait a second oh  that smoldering look  you noticed that too i did go shantae  can you go back to that picture oh look  at that  that's my headshot that's like my  headshot got a little bit of the rock in  them so wait this is how did it come  about  you know they they just reached out to  me and i i'm so  honored i mean maya angelou yes you know  matthew broderick lena horne diane  carroll  vladimir  [Applause]